Okay, we will go ahead and get started. Thank you guys
for showing up again for the final.
Wednesday in this whole series
so we did have that one cancellation a couple
of weeks ago.
Which we unfortunately can't make up.
So this eight weeks study is now a seven week
study.
And so that means that we have to
Omit some material.
So what I'm going to Omit is most of week 7
Okay week seven remember as we went through the flow here. We
had the last two weeks of this. We're going to be about the translation
of the scripture.
And really the first of those two weeks.
Which was week seven is going
to be mostly on the other earlier languages and
then week eight is going to focus mostly on
English. So
I decided to Omit a lot of the
other languages and we're just going to focus on English. So.
You're welcome. No more Greek. No more
Hebrew. We're just going to talk about English today. Although
I would encourage you.
the other languages
are very very important and I
think very very interesting also.
We we did not talk about Latin. We did
not talk about Coptic. We did not talk about Syriac. All
three of those languages were very
very important in the early church.
Syriac meaning the entire eastern part
of the church, which we don't really ever hear much about
but starting in remember Jesus said starting
in Jerusalem, Judea Samaria and the ends of the Earth.
well
Most of our history classes only go
west but that's a radius right? That's a radiating
pattern. And so we have to go east as well. Syriac is
the language which traveled East Latin predominantly
was in the western part of the church.
Talked a little bit about it here and there.
but we're not going to focus on it now and Coptic is
Egyptian
which was very foundational to the early Church in Alexandria and
Egypt, but we're not going to have time to
focus on that one as well. So those
three languages are really other than Greek.
The most important languages that the
Bible has has been translated into at least in early
church. Okay. The Latin Vulgate
was very early and still is
in use today by the clergy in
the Catholic Church.
So we are just going to talk about
the English Bible. Okay, so why
don't I open this up in prayer and then we'll get into it.
Lord we are just delighted Lord for
what you're doing in your body.
Lord you have given us your word you have told us
how you've given your word.
We are able to figure out with your
help and the clues that you've given us Lord how that
word has been Faithfully transmitted down
through the ages for thousands of years.
And Lord this study has been
complicated.
This study has taken us through.
Difficult places in
geography difficult Concepts difficult languages,
we don't read or speak
or understand today.
But Lord, we're going to end today.
And Lord, I just pray that your your blessing will
be upon us Lord as we get to the final final stop.
And that's the Bible that we have today that
we've picked up at Mardels or
ordered on Amazon or
is on our smartphone.
Lord that we can read in our native language
and have the confidence that it is the same book.
That you inspired thousands of years ago.
So thank you for taking us on this journey. Thank you
for revealing yourself. Thank you for just the
the academic knowledge. But Lord also
the knowledge that will hopefully grow us closer to you and
increase our faith.
And increase our defense of the Gospel.
So Lord, I pray that you would do this one last time for
us tonight that you would edify this subset
of your body.
And Lord, I just pray Lord for each one of us
who are here today that we would just walk away just a little
bit closer to you than when we came in.
And we just lift up Troy give him strength as he
teaches in the other room and finishes out that subject as well.
We pray all this in Jesus name. Amen.
English you're familiar with it up on the screen is
a map of all the English speakers
and this is going to be the end of week seven,
but this is where I want to start.
Is English is a very important language? Okay. It
is more important today than when it first started out many of
us don't even know where it came from.
But we speak it. It's our native language for the most part.
And we're fluent in it. And this is how we understand best
words and readings.
So where did it start?
Okay.
I'm glad you asked.
We're going to go back to the early church. Okay, the island
of Britain was occupied.
Before Rome got there, but Rome also occupied it
and tertullian a church father in
North Africa writes at the end of the second century.
All the limits of the Spains and the diverse nations of
the Gauls and the haunts of the Britain inaccessible to
the Romans but subjugated to Christ.
Think about that for just a second political boundaries.
We may not be able to enter.
a place
but God's word.
can
God and His word know no boundaries
Okay, and that's the heart of this this quote
by tertullian.
Romans may not have been able to conquer all of Britain.
But Britain can be subjugated to Christ.
Okay, so that's way back then.
but
Modern English gets it starts not
from the Romans, but from the people who migrate into England
after or what we now know is England
after the Romans have evacuated the area.
So they come in these are the Angles and the Saxons and the
Utes. You may not be descended from.
a German heritage
but your language is
okay, so the angles in the Utes and the
Saxons these were
Germanic peoples who migrated from
the continent over to the island of Britain
and they did that in about the fifth century beginning in
the fifth century.
So old English is very
much Germanic.
Okay, and I will show you some old English here in
a couple slides and I would love to see if
you could read it.
But before we get to that.
Who's our first hero of English scripture?
It's going to be this young English poet named Cadman.
You might be familiar with the Christian band cadman's
call.
They get this namesake from this man caveman.
Well, he had some
dreams. Apparently. This is the tradition. He
had some dreams saying compose this compose this
and so he would take scripture which was only available
in Latin at that time in this area.
And then begin to translate it and sing it and so
the very first English scripture in
the English language was done by
Cadman.
And it was incorporated into his poems
and his songs.
Okay, and look at the dates, this is the middle of the
seventh century.
So we're all familiar with the King James and we know it
to be old in its style. But this is
a thousand years before the King
James.
Okay, this is the first English scripture.
All that we know about Cadman was written down by
this man bead.
All that we know about bead was written down by this man
bead also.
But B department is the father of English History
and one of the most skilled academics
and theologians in his
time.
You can see the dates up there too about the beginning of the 8th century.
And he actually understood a little bit of
Greek.
Now if you hear a few weeks ago and you
you were following along Greek was not known to
people during this time in western part
of Europe and England.
Is about as far west as you can go and still be.
in Europe
So, how did he learn Greek? Well, he picked it up
from an Interlinear that he had. Remember. Nobody could teach him he had
no.
He had no no one to teach him. No one to Mentor him or
show him how Greek worked or teach him the language. He picked
it up just by looking at Greek versus Latin.
He was skilled in Latin and he picked up a little bit of Greek, but
The last 40 days of his life. He translates the
Gospel of John.
In to English. So now we have the Gospel
of John in the English language, but he didn't
translate it from Greek. He translated it from Latin.
Okay, but this is the beginnings of our English scripture
and
bead is one of the heroes of the early what we call what
we would call The Old English times. Okay between about
450 and about 1,000 ad is
what we considered true Old English.
Now here you go. I'm going to take a sip of water quick and I'll
let you chew on this.
version of The Lord's Prayer in Two Old English dialects and
you can see
if you can read it.
Okay long enough give up.
Yeah, if you've been exposed to some German you might
have picked up be able to pick up a few words, but we can't
read this right. This is Old English. This is very much still
the transition from German to English.
So old English we're going to summarize it with this slide.
All of the Old English translations were made from the Latin Vulgate.
Okay, we do not have any old English being taken from
the Greek and the reason being
nobody understood it.
Nobody could read or write or speak it.
So we're going to move on to Middle English. Okay, and this is going
to occupy the time from about 1,000 to
about 1500 ad.
And now you might be familiar with one of the heroes of
the Middle English time, John Wickliffe.
Okay, you've heard of John Wickliffe.
He was an English philosopher and a theologian.
Called The Morning Star of the reformation and he was very
outspoken against the leadership of the Catholic Church.
Okay, he considered them incompetent and
out for gain.
And He was largely correct in that.
But he is credited to be the first person to translate
the entire Bible will give him the New
Testament and he and his associates finished up with
the Old Testament. But at his time he is credited
with the complete Bible in English for the
very first time.
And the date on that was 1384.
Okay, this is now still 250 or so
years before the King James. And before what
else if you remember before the printing press.
So when we look at his work, his work
was a translation of the entire Bible written by
hand.
Okay, he could not just send it to the publisher and have
him print off a couple copies.
but 250 manuscripts
at least
were made 20 of them complete and still
remain to this day.
I don't know that we're going to have a lot of time for storytelling. I
do need to get to the meat of the English
translations here, but Wycliffe did not
die a martyr.
But he was very much hated by the Catholic Church.
Okay, and hated so much that 30 years after
his death.
There was a decision made to dig up his bones and
burn them.
And those bones were then the ash
from the his bones were dumped into the river and there
is a really really good quote, which I do want to
read.
Okay Thomas Fuller in the 17th century
said they burned his bones to ashes and cast him
into the Swift a neighboring Brook running hard by.
Thus the brook hath conveyed his ashes into the Avon Avon
into the Severn Severn into the narrow seas and
they into the main ocean.
And thus the ashes of Wickliffe are the
emblem of his Doctrine which is now dispersed the
world over.
How about that? God can use even an
event like digging up a dead man's
bones?
To exemplify his word going
out to the entire.
Earth
so very cool story tragic that it happened but
a very cool story and how God used it for his glory.
And that of course burned what we now know is Wycliffe
Bible translators. Okay, you can go to their page and
There are still people on Earth today who do not
have the Bible in their language. That is
something that Wycliffe lived for died for.
And he would be very honored that
his name is being carried over today with an
organization. That's trying to do the same thing in our
time.
So you can go there to their website and see which languages they
still need. But let's summarize Middle English Middle English.
All Middle English translations were
made from the Latin Vulgate including Wycliffe.
Not from the biblical languages because because 1500
ad.
Is still too early.
We do not yet have the humanists and their education of the
Greek and the Hebrew.
Into Western Europe, so everything in the English language
up to Modern English.
Is going to be from the Latin.
Okay.
One moment while I switch.
presentations here
So what happens after Wickliffe?
Well English becomes much much more important
on a global scale.
Okay, it becomes much more important England becomes
a military superpower and the English
language and the culture.
Is being spread and more important becoming more
important outside of Britain as well. And of course,
we all know that
it then transfers over to our continent as well.
Okay. So Modern English is where we are at and
with Modern English. There are grammatical reasons
why it's called Middle English or sorry Modern
English.
But there's also now a turning point with Biblical scholarship.
Okay. Now we actually have people with the faculties to
understand read write understand speak.
The biblical languages which we didn't have in the
early and Middle English.
Okay, so our first big hero of Modern English is
going to be William Tyndale. You've probably heard of William
Tyndale as well.
He is credited as being the first person.
to translate the Bible
the New Testament at least from the original languages
into English
Okay, and he started on the Old Testament
as well because he was fluent in Hebrew as well.
But God did not allow him
to live long enough.
to finish that job
because he added out with the King.
King Henry at the time
about his marriage and the King didn't
like him and the church didn't like him and he was
handed over and he was strangled to death.
And burned at the stake.
his dying words
Lord open the king of England's eyes.
Imagine that a martyr for wanting people to know the
Bible.
in their native language
is killed
and here's his dying words. It's a prayer not
just for the king. But that this work that
God was using him for would continue on.
Okay, it didn't matter to him that
he wasn't going to be involved any longer. He wanted God's work
to continue. Do you see that in the in the heart of
the of the quote?
But what did he want? There's a really really famous
conversation here, which is worth reading here.
About a dialogue an argument between William Tyndale and
a clergyman inside the Catholic Church the clergyman
tells Tyndale we had better be without God's laws
than the popes.
Tyndale responded I defy the Pope
and all his laws and if God
spares my life air many years. I will cause the boy
that driveth the plow to know more of the scriptures than
you do.
That's one of my favorite quotes in all of church history.
Look at what he's look at what he's saying?
tyndale's heart
I want the I want the boy that drives the
plows to know God's word.
God's word is not just meant for you.
High UPS in the church
It's meant for everybody. He could
have chosen anybody but to choose the plowboy
is relevant and indicative of
his comment that he wants everybody to know God's word. Everybody
has a fundamental right to have access.
to the Bible
Tyndale died for that
Tyndale died for that it was his mission in life to
do it and it was his prayer and death.
That it would continue on.
So because the church did not like him and this work
was so outlawed that there's only four copies
remaining today.
They were all destroyed only four remain today of
tyndale's work Tyndale was able to take advantage of
the printing press.
Okay, so he did not have to copy by hand.
So there was many many copies made but most of them were
destroyed.
How important was tyndale's work? Well up
to 83% of the King James and our
modern New Testament is derived directly from
William Tyndale
and his pioneering work in the New Testament.
well
If you're going to make some enemies why.
What was it about his work and his translation that had
the church so up in arms.
I've got a couple examples here and it's it's worth our time
to to investigate some of these.
Jesus when he asked Peter in a
very famous conversation
Who do you say that? I am?
Jesus says that to Peter
And Peter says I believe you're the Son of God, right? And Jesus says
yes, and on this
rock. I will build my church. Well.
Wycliffe in 1384 translated he translates
it Church.
Okay Tyndale comes and he translated congregation
on this rock. I will build my congregation.
Now the Greek word EK lesia is actually
better translated congregation.
Tyndale was on to something.
in 1610 the douay Reams,
let me get
A pointer up here so you can see along.
the douay Reams in 1610 is a Catholic version
of the Bible and it goes back to
use the word Church King James
himself in his version in 1611
gives the authority to say no. Look we're
going to go back and use the word church.
So it was really King James and his decision.
That we all say in our familiar with the word church today
in the Protestant church.
Okay. If not for that we would be calling this a
congregation. We do use
that term but church was largely.
a derivative of the Catholic tradition
Why did the church have a problem with the word congregation? Well,
it made everybody in here.
equal
to
the head of the church or the pastor or in that
case the priest and the Catholic Church did not
want anything to do with that.
They liked having it to where they could lure it over the people.
Okay, so that's why they wouldn't allow a Bible in their language.
And that's why they did not like the term congregation.
another thing in Acts 14:23
where Paul is appointing Elders Wycliffe translates
priests.
They appointed priests in all the churches and all
the cities Tyndale changes that word to elders.
The douay Reams changes it back to priests.
And then King James does go
forward with tyndale's interpretation here.
And the Greek word presbyteras is
better translated as elders.
That's why we have Elders in our church. Today is
because a Tyndale.
And his use of the word Elders for this Greek
word as opposed to priests.
And one more and this is probably the biggest one Acts 2:38.
Peter said to him do ye pennants?
So, how do we be? How do we get saved? Do ye pennants?
That's what Wycliffe says in Acts 2:38
as Peter is preaching at Pentecost.
Tyndale
says repent
the Catholic do a reams of 1610 reverts back
to Due pennants.
And King James thankfully continues on with tyndale's repent.
The Greek word is metanoia for
repentance. It's a compound word. It means
meta after and no us
a thought. It's an afterthought repentance as
Tyndale rightly new is all in the
mind. It is a thought it is not an action repentance
is not an action. It's not something you
do. It's something you think.
And Tyndale rightly knew that about the word and
he took the verbal aspect out of the the
action-oriented verb out of
the translation and thankfully.
The Protestant Bibles from there on have done the
same.
Okay, you can see how important tyndale's work
was and why the church at that time was
so much against it.
So here's a brief list of all the things that that Tyndale
has coined whether words or phrases that we
just take for granted let there be light.
It came to pass eat drink and be merry.
No, man can serve two masters.
Passover scapegoat, these are all words that were and phrases
that were coined by Tyndale.
in his pioneering English Bible
that we are now read in ours.
And take for granted many times.
Okay, so Tyndale had given his life for
this.
Now we're going to find a pretty much a linear road
all the way to the King James and I'm
going to go rather quickly because we've got a lot of Bibles to cover here.
so Coverdale miles Coverdale
Is the successor he had taken basically tyndale's work
and added to it in the Old Testament where Tyndale
didn't translate and so Coverdale and his
Bible of 1535 is now the first complete printed
English Bible. Okay, because Tyndale didn't finish
the Old Testament.
So Coverdale did finish it, but covered El
didn't take it from the Hebrew. He took it from the
German and the Latin.
And he added it to tyndale's work. So we
don't yet have a complete Bible from the original languages. But
this is the next step in the process.
and look below
dedicated to the king and queen with no serious opposition.
A year later Tyndale will give his life.
This is a year before that happens.
And God is already beginning to answer his dying
prayer.
We can see God at work.
And God is often at work. Well, we pray and even
before we pray.
Right, and this is proof.
in history that that's true
Matthew's Bible 15:37 published by
John Rogers under the pen name of Thomas
Matthew. He used a pen name because later on
when England was ruled by the Catholic
Queen Mary Mary Tudor.
He was running for his life got caught and he was later
burned at the stake. So another man giving his
life.
For Bible translation in our language.
So we
Can have it and have access to it?
the great Bible
Henry the eighth the same man who had William Tyndale
murdered martyred
Has now authorized for the church an English
Bible to be translated and that's what
this is. This is the first one to be authorated authorized by
the king.
the great Bible called the great Bible because it was
very large
Not because it was great but because it was large.
as we move on
now when Mary does take the throne the Protestants have
to run for their lives. So the Protestants
are going to hop over the channel into
the continent and they're going to flee down
to Geneva and they're going to come up with their translation
of the Bible in English in Geneva. We call
it the Geneva Bible.
Well, who did they meet in Geneva? Well at that time it was the
head was John Calvin. You've probably heard of John
Calvin. John Calvin was French.
But he was more than happy to help them
with their translation. I don't know how much he knew
English, but he was more than happy to supply them notes that were anti-catholic.
Doctrine
so this Bible was most famous for its notes and
you can see that there is text.
And then there is a whole bunch of notes around that
text. It had copious copious notes.
The other thing this Bible was famous for
It now has verses.
All the Bibles before the Geneva Bible did not
have verses right if you remember.
verses were created verse numbers were
created
in 1551 by stefanus in
his Greek addition. We talked about that about four weeks
ago.
The timing is now that diverse has exist and
they show up for the first time in the Geneva Bible
in English.
Okay.
very very popular bible
Shakespeare Cromwell
The Mayflower pilgrims the Jamestown colonists the
very first Bible in English in this continent was the
Geneva Bible.
So what was Calvin's influence? Well, let me
read you a couple of his notes.
And you'll find out.
the notes on Revelation
That is the Pope.
with hatch with hatch
Which hath his power out of hell?
and cometh stents
on Revelation 17:4
the woman is the Antichrist. That is the Pope.
with the whole body of his filthy creatures
These are in the study Guides of the Geneva Bible the
study notes.
Okay, you see what the church is doing? It's a very much a battle
between the Protestant church and the Catholic church.
We can't appreciate it as much these days.
But that's what was going on.
They can't alter the text, but they can sure put their opinions in
the sidebars and that's exactly what Calvin did
with this Bible.
The Bishop's Bible is next 1568.
The Geneva Bible was deemed two calvinistic for
the established church of England. So the second authorized Bible
remember, the first one was the great Bible of 1539 here.
We are 30 years later and this
is The Bishop's Bible is now ordained and
commissioned as a authorized Bible
for the church.
This Bible is going to be the base for
the King James.
Which will be coming at about 50 years after this.
Not to be outdone.
The Catholics when a Protestant takes the throne.
Now have to run for their lives.
And they flee across the channel and
go into the continent and they established themselves that
do a in France.
And they establish a seminary and they
begin work on their translation.
of the Bible
Well, you can expect since the Geneva Bible
was so anti-catholicism that this Bible is
also going to contain notes, which would be anti protestantism.
That's exactly what we get in
Matthew 6:24 the notes say you cannot serve
two masters God and bail Christ and
Calvin.
Not sure how helpful this is for getting to know the Lord.
In a deeper and more personal way.
But this is what we find in the margins. This
is what was going on at the time.
One thing also I didn't mention about the Geneva Bible.
It is the first one to be translated in
its entirety from the original languages.
So all of the Old Testament is now from Hebrew all of
the New Testament is now from Greek.
After the do-way Reams in 1610 we go to 1611 and
here is our King James.
We've talked a lot about the King James.
There is a lot of emotion attached even present
day to the King James.
Okay, I grew up learning verses and
memorizing verses from the King James. Maybe a
lot of you did too. Maybe a lot of you still do.
One of the things we need to be careful about.
is idolizing
a version
of God's word
and that's one of the things that I want to take very very
cautiously tread very cautiously on
is that there are people today who really get emotionally attached
to this and really get animated and antagonistic against
other versions.
even saw YouTube video not long ago
where they're calling people who are King James proponents are calling all
the modern versions that came after that basically satanic.
of the devil
Okay. So what I don't want to do in
this class is put a
version of the book on a pedestal
what I tried to do and as we've walked along through the
history of this process of getting God's word from God
to us is understand the historical context.
of the King James
so that when we encounter the King James, which we are right
now, we will be better informed and better equipped to
understand what the King James actually is.
King James is a beautiful translation.
It is a wonderful translation. It is a very accurate and a very
faithful translation.
but remember what we talked about it is
a very good translation of
about 15 or 16
manuscripts
That were confined to the Greece and Turkey area of
the Byzantine Empire.
In the 10th of the 15th centuries.
Okay, so it is a very accurate translation of a
fairly
modern from this time
Byzantine text
of the church
over a thousand years removed from when the writings were
original of the New Testament.
Okay, so we have to understand the historical context
of the King James.
Before we can allow those emotions.
to really grip us and
get the conversation and the debate heated.
Okay, this is until fairly recently
the most popular translation of
the Bible in any language. It has since been overtaken.
The King James is very very Monumental and
very much an important work in the history
of the Bible.
1611 was the King James. It was
commissioned by King James himself.
Because the people loved the Geneva Bible.
the church loved Bishop's Bible
and he didn't want to versions.
So he said okay Scholars, give us
one.
To be read by the church.
And they did and they did a good job.
And it still remains today to be very loved and very popular.
So here we have it's very linear in the early modern English
time frame between Tyndale and the
King James. It's very linear. We talked about one Bible after another
coming out each getting a
little bit more refined.
as we go
but all of these Bibles you'll remember are taken
from what Greek text
the textus receptus.
These were the more modern the younger Greek.
Manuscripts from the 10th to the 15th century. They
did not yet at this time. Either have or appreciate
all of the many manuscripts.
We would find from earlier in the church.
Okay that happens after the King James.
How are we doing on time? Okay.
We're going to plow through.
Modern English Bibles and we're not certainly going
to talk about all of them because we would be here to late Thursday
if we did.
But our first stop in the Modern English Bibles is
going to be this revised version.
This was the only authorized and recognized revision
of the King James version.
Okay, this was an authorized revision of the King James.
Maybe you didn't know that but they are
not going to be using the Texas receptus because
what happened just before 1885 was
West cotton Hort had published their
Greek New Testament.
Which had abandoned the Texas receptus?
in favor of all of the
older manuscripts
that they had found in that intermediate time between King
James and now would now
is 1885.
And this was done in Britain.
And it included American Scholars who
they largely ignored.
but
they had published.
This English version which had abandoned the Texas
receptus and by doing so they had come
up with their version which had about 30,000 changes.
from the King James
So very different when you use a different
manuscript base, you're going to get lots of differences. Okay, and
by textual criticism last week.
We have explained a lot of those variances.
Okay, that's the power of textual criticism
in the beauty of why we talk about that before we do this.
Just makes everything sit in context a little bit more clear.
So now the Americans because the British Scholars
largely ignored their suggestions said
well, we want to publish our own.
and
the British scholar said okay, but you have to wait 14 years. We
have an exclusivity period of 14 years.
As I said, okay.
So they work on their American version of this
and it becomes a 1901 published as
the American Standard Version.
It's very it's more Americanized versus it's American
English versus English.
Okay, instead of the Holy Ghost. We see the Holy Spirit. Okay,
things like that.
this Bible
has become
the basis for most of our Modern English translations
Okay, it was used as a base for the revised Standard
Version the new revised Standard
Version the English Standard Version The New American
Standard Bible.
And then the living Bible and some others.
We can get lost in the acronyms. It's easy to
do. I'm going to try and keep us on task, but it's easy to
get a lot of these confused. I know.
But 30,000 differences.
a lot of people who were
part of the tradition the old school who loved the King James
and these new modern versions were coming out and
changing God's word.
They were getting this same thing that this YouTube video did
of this can't be from God.
What are you doing? You're corrupting God's word. You're taking out
all of this stuff, right?
and here is one of these places where the American Standard
Version and then by derivative all of the Modern English
versions since
Have been criticized. Okay, John 6:47.
The King James says verily verily I say unto you he that
believeth on me hath everlasting life.
The new American or the American Standard Version of 1901 says I
say unto you he that believeth.
hath eternal life
And the ESV says something very similar so they
were criticized you're taking.
the object of Faith out of the verse
Jesus says believe on me.
You're taking the on me out. That's the most important part.
the problem is
That's not very.
accurate
of a criticism
and we can prove it all of these objections to the Modern English.
Bible are very very testable.
And so we can test it here.
Did the American Standard Version and everything subsequent have
a theological problem with Jesus being the object
of our faith?
No.
Because just seven verses before in John 6:40.
It reads in the American Standard Version for this is
the will of my father that everyone that beholdeth the son and believeth
on him.
Should have eternal life.
So you see there's no problem with Jesus. There's no problem with Believing on
him as the object of our faith.
The people with the criticisms did not do the due diligence.
To actually see if that was the case. We let emotions.
Grip us.
in a lot of these arguments and confrontations
very testable
so why is it missing in that verse well because of textual criticism.
We know that the oldest manuscripts did not contain the
words. So those words were not put in
the Modern English versions.
It doesn't mean they have a theological problem with those words because those words
are on all these other verses.
It's just for this verse.
It was not original.
In that text and so they were omitted.
Another one Colossians 1:14 in whom
we have Redemption through his blood even the Forgiveness of
sins.
The ASV ESV say in whom we have our Redemption the
Forgiveness of sins. They left out through his blood.
You guys have a problem with?
the blood
atonement of Jesus. Why did you take it out?
Well, did they take it out?
Colossians is very much a parallel
with Ephesians and we can go to Ephesians in
the in the American Standard Version in Ephesians
1:7 which reads in whom we have our Redemption
through his blood the Forgiveness of
our trespasses according to the riches of his grace.
They don't have a theological problem with Jesus. They don't
have a theological problem with the blood.
of Jesus as our atonement
It just was not present in the original versions
of Colossians, but was later added.
Because of the parallel passage in Ephesians, okay, we
can deduce this we can test this now.
looking back
Okay, here we go. We're going to do a run through.
And as I go through some of these modern versions,
you're probably going to be thinking
as I'm talking boy. This guy doesn't like
any of them.
Please I do. I like a lot of them.
But as tour guide along this whole process
along this whole journey, I do want
to bring out some things and be more transparent maybe then.
the translators have been
and I just want to inform.
I'm not condemning. I'm not telling you which ones
to to go do and which ones to stay away from except
for one case.
But I'm just pointing out a lot of the things which might be easily overlooked.
Okay, the revised standard version of 1952. We've
had a 50-year gap now.
this version was supposed to be out there for the
scholarship the academics.
Something that was Modern what happened before 1952 well
in 1947 the Dead
Sea Scrolls.
were discovered
So now we have more data.
So the RSV relies pretty heavily on
the Dead Sea Scrolls for the Old Testament.
Okay, so but it proved to be very unpopular.
And today only has you know less than 5% of
the market share by 1990.
But this was the basis now.
for
the ESV
Okay, we're going to show how we got there.
But before we do one of the things that the RSV was
criticized for was it has taken a lot
of the Old Testament prophecies.
And divorced them from the New Testament
fulfillments of those prophecies.
Okay, and one good example of that is here in the
American Standard Version of Isaiah 7:14. Therefore the
Lord himself will give you a sign Behold a virgin shall
conceive and bear a son shall call his name
Emmanuel.
The RSV changes that virgin to
a young woman.
oh, that's
a big difference
but maintains in Matthew the Fulfillment of
that Behold a virgin shall conceive and
bear son. So why did they change it to a young woman?
It's because they're treating the old and the new
independently.
And they're translating the Hebrew word Alma.
as young woman
when very clearly in the New Testament Matthew is using
the Greek word parthenos.
as virgin
so we understand that Isaiah is forecasting and
foretelling prophesying the Virgin birth.
But because the RSV is treating him independently we get this young
woman.
Okay, a lot of people were were turned off.
By that a lot of conservatives were
turned off by that.
now the one which I will tell you to stay away from
1961 the New World Translation
Put out by the Watchtower Society. Those are the
Jehovah's Witnesses.
Okay.
It is a an entirely heretical translation that
diminishes the person of Jesus Christ and I
will show you exactly what I mean.
John 1:1
in the beginning was the word and the Word was with God and the Word was
God King James.
We see it in the ESV even in
the Catholic the modern Catholic Bible in 1950s.
But what they do in the New World Translation is
they change it to in the beginning was the word and the
Word was with God and the Word was a god.
Oh.
That changes our interpretation entirely, doesn't
it?
Now they have their reason for it.
but their reason is incorrect and all of the
people who know Greek grammar would tell you it's incorrect.
to translate it with an indefinite a versus
a definite the
but what did the New World Translation do?
They didn't tell us who their translators were. They left
that page blank. You can go to the front of your Bible and
you can find out exactly who translated your Bible.
Okay, all their names and all their credentials are listed there.
But at the beginning of this they leave it blank. Why did
they leave it blank?
Quote they did not want to advertise themselves. But
let all the glory go to the author of the scriptures God.
Well, that's fine.
Except we want to know if they know what they're talking
about. That's why they put their names in the
front of the Bible.
And it was later found out that only one person on the Translating committee
had any knowledge of the original languages of the
Bible.
at all
So they were not able to make this translation. This translation
was entirely made to suit their Theology and
we can show you another example Colossians 1 we
get a beautiful doxology from Paul.
Telling us who Jesus really is. He
is the Creator God.
all things were created
by him
But they changed this to say because by
means of him all other things.
Were created in the heavens all other things
have been created through him and he is
also before all other things that word
other.
Is not in the Greek.
It's not in any manuscript. It's not in any Greek text.
It's hidden.
hidden from the reader
To support a theology which we know is
incorrect.
Okay.
moving on
1966 the Jerusalem bible
What happened before 1966? This is a Catholic
version in 1943. The pope makes a
declaration that now you can.
Study the original languages.
Now you can translate from the original languages.
into English
Or any other language before that, where did you have to get your
your scripture from?
The Latin you had to get it from the Latin
which is not original. It is a translation.
But now in 1943 the pope makes that declaration. And
for the first time we have an English Bible called the
Jerusalem bible that was taken from the original languages.
Jr. Are Tolkien had been a part of this.
He translated the Book of Jonah.
And this was later updated in 1985
to the New Jerusalem bible.
And I have not read it. But from
what I hear and have looked at it seems like a very competent.
Translation of the scripture, but this is widely used
in the English-speaking Catholic Church.
So the American Standard Bible gives way to The New
American Standard Bible in 1971.
This was published to be a conservative alternative
to the revised Standard Version the RSV, which
we talked about a few slides ago.
It's considered to be one of the more or
the most literal translation of
the original languages.
Okay, and when I say literal?
We need to understand that literal.
Does not equal best.
literal means literal
that means every word comes across and sometimes
it's very hard to read because we just don't
read that way. Okay, so literal does
not mean best. It just means literal word
for word.
Although it is a very good translation.
The living Bible of 1971 many of
you probably know this.
Kenneth Taylor
was doing his devotions out of the King James with his
kids and said well, maybe there's a way to paraphrase this to make
it more understandable for my kids.
And so the living Bible was created.
out of that concept
It is a paraphrase which is the opposite now of.
Literal, okay literal word for
word.
Paraphrase is now.
thought for thought
a paraphrase will take the original languages and translate
out a sentence and then rearrange the
wording of that sentence and add some
things to make it more readable and understandable.
So you have a very different feel.
From The New American Standard to say the living Bible. Okay,
they're going to read very differently, but they're
both taken from the original languages. Okay.
the NIV
started in well before 1978 but
first version published in 1978.
We will.
Talk about this, okay.
It is now the most popular bible.
in history
in any language
Okay by terms of volume and sales.
What they're doing though in recent updates to
the NIV?
Is they've adopted this thing called gender neutrality
and we talked a little bit about it last week as kind of a primer.
But gender neutrality was brought out by
the new revised Standard Version, but here
in the NIV in 1992.
They adopted a new philosophy on
how to translate the Bible in terms of its masculinity. Okay.
The Bible is very masculine book. It is
a lot of the pronouns are masculine a
lot of the
A lot of the objects and a lot
of the conversation is all dictated to
us in masculine terms.
That doesn't necessarily leave.
Women out it's just how God
transmitted it in the culture that he was in
or the culture that the authors were in but as
we can see in the niv's adopted philosophy.
They wanted to change that.
It's two masculine. They wanted to change it. They say
in part of their their guide authors of
the biblical books.
Sometimes can offend modern sensibilities.
The patriarchalism. Okay, that's all the masculinity of
the Bible.
Can tend to deny the common human dignity of
all hearers and readers.
Okay, how does that sound?
This is the philosophy that the NIV has adopted.
had adopted in 1992
Let's look at an example here.
In the NIV of 1984. So before
that Psalm 1 1 to 3, okay.
Blessed is the man who does not walk into counsel the
wicked or stand the way of Sinners sitting a seat of mockers. But his
Delight is in the law of the Lord and in his law he
meditates on it day and night you see how masculine this
is. We have the hymns the he's
after they adopted
the gender-neutral philosophy in 1992
They wanted to publish an update in 1996. They published
it in.
the UK
in which they wanted to adopt this philosophy and
change all of these pronouns to
Neutral pronouns take the heat out
of it take the hymn out of it.
Okay, so in 1996, they wanted to do that,
but the conservative readership of the NIV here
in the states would have nothing to do with that.
Okay, they said no, we don't want that.
We don't want that so they said okay, we won't
do it here in the states. We're going to publish it in the UK.
And so they did in 1996. They published
it in the UK.
a little bit later in 2005
They made an update to make it more readable.
Okay, they wanted to make this thing they
called ultimately the tniv the today's
New International Version in 2005.
So this was an international version not
a US version and look how this reads here
in the same Psalm blessed. Are those who do
not walk?
But who Delight in the law of the Lord and meditate on
his law day and night. They are like a
stream or tree planted by streams of water. You see
what they did. They took the Heat and the hymn out.
But this got blasted.
Why did it get blasted not just because of the gender neutrality, but
what also did they do? They didn't affect just gender they affected.
number
the beauty of this Psalm doesn't lie
in the he and the hymn it lies in.
the soul the soul believer
Who is in the midst of the world?
Who's being tempted by a group of people?
It's a singular believer not being
tempted to go along with a plurality of
the world.
That's what this Psalm is about.
And they have completely.
obliterated that
they didn't just make it gender neutral. They made it number.
plural
and so they did get criticized for this the tniv was
not a good seller so they wanted to update this and
so they did but what did they
do for the NIV in 2011? Well, they brought.
in under the name NIV
they snuck in their gender neutrality, which they said
they wouldn't do.
They brought in their gender neutrality. And now
we have blessed is the one it's just one we fixed it. No,
but it's not masculine. It's
it's neutral.
Okay, so
How we feel about gender neutrality?
is one thing
but I think we can agree that.
Maybe the reasons why they're doing it. We're a
little bit of a stretch.
So as to not offend the modern reader.
Should we be worried about how God's word offends people?
I don't think so.
If God wrote it, I don't want to apologize for it.
Okay, so instead of apologizing for
it, they change the wording now.
Is this Psalm only talking about a male?
can only a male
be affected and and in
is this only talking about a man? No.
I think it's pretty clear.
But again, so it's not the read it's not the it's not
whether they did it. It's the reasons behind why they're
doing it. So gender neutrality is one
and I think people people tend to fall on either side of
the camp.
Okay, and how you feel about it your opinions?
are valid but know that other people will disagree and
in some cases I can see both sides of this.
But the reasons why we're doing this I believe is
off.
The new King James the new King James of 1982.
It was not an authorized revision of the King
James.
It was not.
It was a work meant to modernize the
King James.
Okay.
The new King James is a very literal translation.
We don't have the V and The Vow
anymore of the King James.
It's been updated. It's been modernized in its
language. It's still uses.
the textus receptus
and it is the only Bible to my
knowledge or at least one of the very very rare and
few Bibles that today.
Still uses the textus receptus.
as its base text
But it's a very literal and very good translation.
The nrsv. So this is an update to the
RSV of 1950. So here in
1989 1990.
They wanted to modernize and put
something out a little bit more for the scholars again, and
you can see it's intended to serve as
a translation for devotional liturgical scholarly needs
of the broadest number of religious adherents.
Maybe maybe we're watering it down a little too much if that's
our goal.
The version was most popular among liberal Scholars
and in scholarly Publications, they continue
the trend of divorcing the old
and a new testament that the RSV did
and they now introduced gender neutrality.
So here's some of their scholarly writings in Genesis
1 2
The Earth was without form and void in the darkness was upon the face
of the deep. And the spirit of God was moving they say a wind
from God was moving.
Just because you can translate a word some way
doesn't mean you should.
most English Bibles
have continued on with the spirit, but this
one was different.
Matthew 18:15, I love this one. If your
brother sins against you go and tell him his fault between you and
him alone. When you neutralize that it reads like this. If
another member of the church sins against you go
and point out the Fault when the two of you are alone if the
member listens to you, you have regained that one.
now
Jesus tells us that we're brothers and sisters
were children of God.
By definition that's familial terms.
terminology
nothing is more intimate.
Than family relations and that's why
we're given that terminology.
think of how
non-intimate this sounds
if that member
sins against me and we go and have a private discussion. I've
regained that one.
How personal is that? How intimate is
that?
That's not at all what Jesus was talking about. You
lose that intimacy for the sake of neutrality.
The new living is not an update to the living Bible. It is
a original translation from the original but it
is a very paraphrased reading of
the original.
And I think a very it's this second most popular
English Bible on unit sales.
Okay, I've read the new living.
Front to back it's very very good.
very good if you want to sit down and take in God's word and
you have a couple hours at a time and do
it boy, you'll
You'll get really close to the Lord. Just reading.
And not having the distractions of just reading his word. It's very
readable.
Now we get to the ESV. Who's the Bible we use in this church?
Okay.
Very good very literal.
but
for sake of transparency, we'll point out that it also carries bias.
It has a calvinistic bias to it. Okay, if
you have a more calvinist leaning theology,
you probably don't mind or probably don't even notice this
but one example where it comes up is
in the RSV. It says in first John three eight to
nine he who commits sin is of the devil.
In the ESV it says he who makes a practice of sinning.
Is of the devil?
In verse 18 here at the bottom.
Of chapter 5 we know that anyone born of God does not sin that
is a literal translation of the Greek.
The ESV says we know that everyone who has been born
of God does not keep on sinning.
They have taken some Liberties here. Okay, they have used
this Calvin influence and they have expanded
and interpreted the text for you. The only
thing I would say that's
That I don't particularly like of this and this is just me
as I wish they would be open when doing so, okay. There
are ways to say we have Supply these extra words in
interpretation.
But they chose not to do that. So when we read it.
We're expecting a literal translation, but we
don't always get it.
Okay, the message 2002.
I don't know what more to say about this and we're coming up on time, but
It is not the word of God.
the message by Eugene Peterson
Is more of a sermon?
It's more of a devotional.
Than a rendition of God's word.
See if this is The Lord's Prayer that you remember with a God Like
This loving you. You can pray very simply like this.
Our Father in Heaven reveal who you are set the
world, right
Do what's best As Above So Below Keep
Us Alive with three Square meals?
Keep us forgiven with you and forgiving others keep us
safe from ourselves and the devil you're in
charge. You can do anything you want. You're Ablaze and
Beauty. Yes. Yes.
The Lord's Prayer
courtesy of the message
you see how this is not a literal rendition of
God's word. It is capturing the meaning of
this but more in a devotional.
Way, this is how a pastor would
preach through this rather than a reading of
the word of God.
A couple other ones here Jesus when
he tells Nicodemus you must be born again to enter the Kingdom of
Heaven is very straightforward. Even if being born again is a difficult concept
to understand.
But the message renders this this way Jesus said you're
not listening. Let me say it again unless a
person submits to this original creation the
wind hovering over the water Creation The Invisible
moving the visible a baptism into
a new life. It's not possible to enter God's Kingdom.
I don't know about you, but
Jesus was a little bit more straightforward.
This becomes a little bit more cumbersome and I don't know if
I'm coming or gone in this.
Is it harmful? I don't believe it's harmful. I just believe it's a little
confusing.
Okay, I think a lot of the message has good intentions, but
it can come across rather confusion confusing.
Last one I'm going to go through is The Net Bible? Okay, 2005.
So we're getting into this.
Now into this century 21st century
net is a kind of
a dual meaning net for new English translation
and net meaning internet.
It is a free online resource and
it was intended to be so.
Okay, what's brilliant about this version is
all of its copious copious notes.
If you were at all interested in
this series that we're talking about and want
to know more about why did a translator choose to
translate it this way versus this way or which manuscripts does
have this reading versus that reading?
Well here is Psalms 1 and
here are all the notes.
That they surround the text with that have
just that type of information in it 60,000 notes.
In this translation headed up by people like Dan
Wallace who's very much a text critic and very much up to
speed on all the stuff that we've talked about in here.
And you have a lot of notes that you
can get from this. They're all there and the printed version and
they're all hyperlinked. I believe in the online version.
So take advantage of of that kind
of scholarship that is free and out there if you
want it.
all right, so
to summarize
and then we'll stop.
We have a spectrum don't we we have a spectrum.
Of what I think are good reliable renderings
of God's word.
But there's a spectrum and this now comes down to
preference. What is it that you want?
Do you want something that is what we would
call formal equivalents? Okay word for
word. Do you want something that's going to take every word that's in
the Hebrew and the Greek and translated to an equivalent
English word.
You can get that. Okay, we talked about The New
American Standard being, you know, one of the best at that.
What you sacrifice when you get that is readability.
It might be difficult to understand.
It won't flow.
Okay, but you will get word for word.
On the other end of the spectrum we get the
paraphrases and so you have on this end you have the message
and the living Bible and the New Living Translation.
Okay, you have these you have these paraphrases where
you get thought for thought.
Instead of the word for word and what do you sacrifice you sacrifice
a lot of the ability to study.
You won't know which words are there just for
readability or which words were there for you know that were
there in the originals? Okay, so you'll lose a little
bit of that.
and then there are plenty of versions in the middle, which
Appear to draw from both of these. Okay, so there is a spectrum
from
Literal word for word, but without
the readability all the way to paraphrase thought
for Thought which are more readable but to sacrifice
the study.
aspect of the scripture
So how do you choose and this will be our last slide of the
entire one?
Which one is best?
well
As you could probably guess I'm going to say it depends.
It depends on what you want. What do you want?
And there's two things which I've recommended here for people
to do with regards to God's word.
How do you take it in? How do you ingest it two things?
You can do want us to study.
And want us to soak.
Okay, study and soak.
If you're going to study you're going to want a more word for
word. You're going to want a more formal equivalent translation of
the Bible.
Okay, if you're wanting to soak soak meaning.
Taken afternoon off.
Sit down in your lawn chair open up the Bible
and just read for hours.
Soaking in God's word. You're going to want something that's a
little bit more readable.
Okay, but might not have the word for word.
So which ones are best for study?
well
the new King James ESV The New American Standard
They're kind of leading the pack. Okay, they're leading the
pack as far as their their balance between readability but
being fundamentally very good at being literal.
And word for word and containing aspects
in it that you can actually study.
And get closer to the Lord.
We've talked about which text do they use? Well,
remember the ESV in The New American Standard used the critical
text. The older manuscripts the new King
James the King James are going to use the Texas receptus.
the more modern manuscripts
Okay, so that might be a personal preference but I think texture criticism
has led us toward the accuracy of the older manuscripts.
Okay.
So those can be some personal preference.
So what I would recommend if you're
not even knowing where to start.
if you just have
I've got this Bible, but is it is it the
right one? Is it the best one for me? What I would recommend if you're
trying to study God's word.
And wanting to be faithful and you're not sure about the differences
in the manuscripts and maybe we still don't understand that fully
and completely what I would recommend did you do?
Is just get side by side.
And ESV and a new King James.
If you want to start somewhere start out
with an ESV and a King James or New King James side
by side and read them and see how
different they are.
Knowing that they pull from different texts, but what you can be assure
of and certain of is that while there
are differences in those some verses will be at not in
one and they'll be any other.
What you can be sure of.
is that this is as wide of variance as
there is
there's nothing further out to the left or further
out to the right.
The differences in the ESV and the new King James are going
to be the widest that the variations
ever get.
So there's not going to be some new wild text
out there somewhere and some other version. No the
boundaries of the scripture.
Can be seen in those two versions.
Or if you have a new American Standard compare that with the
new King James or you want to do the Old
King James and the old American Standard you can do that, too.
But if you're wanting to study and wanting to know the differences in
God's word and how you can soak it in and how you can study.
This will be my recommendations for you.
We're at 7:30. I think they even wanted
me to stop 10 minutes ago.
But that is it. You guys have made it
for eight minus one seven weeks.
This has been very complicated stuff. You guys have been Troopers and
putting up with this. There's a lot that is just going to go over your
head. You need to hear it more than once, that's fine. Please email
me. Text me call
me. Just stop me. If you have any questions about anything we covered.
I would love to sit down with you and go over it
with you.
But this has been a blast for me.
I've been encouraged by seeing you guys showing up
every week and taking this in. So thank you all very much.
Appreciate it.